we should do a top 10 movies in the last
decade better yet we should just do a
reaction to watch Mojo's top 10 best
movies the last decade
I asked ways that's way easier we and
your people would rather watch that for
some reason I like debating over the
list mm-hmm you're a master debater
always divisive what they gotta say this
is a top work your very request from
patron Eric Horstman let's watch this
you decades come and go hope I've seen
all these what what tell with your list
I would have put both of those on there
it's number one
perfectly to good movies just to give at
this film woke up thinking about it
it's like communication terrible that
demonstrates the importance of
communication so cool Quentin Tarantino
has remained one of the industry's most
distinctive and exhilarating voices
among the three films he made during the
2010 Django Unchained was arguably his
most audacious cutting his Willis is
most fun his name is Django he's a free
man like a master chef Tarantino
combined
[Music]
is it pretty
what about get out
yeah dramas such as this easily could
have come out in the late sixties or
seventies drawing parallels to classics
like Rosemary's Baby The Exorcist and
the omen turn breeze what do you mean
at the same time beretta Terry still
feels like a product of the 2010
touching upon mental health and trauma
with a modern sensibility where as so
many other hormones literally jump out
at the audience
the rector re after lures us in with
tents foreshadowing and subtle scares
leaving us completely unprepared when
insanity takes over number six the wolf
of Wall Street capitalism
[Music]
and so many influencers love quoting him
on West Bentley's in this movie yep
Everage clip i see on reminded of that
fact i totally forgot
people always say I look like noodles
you do you look exactly like him I don't
know which one to shoot didn't fall or
not law all and deserved it not this
meaningful
we can actually try to survive in an
unexpected world come to embrace his
true identity never free Mad Max fury
road in today's blockbuster land it's
gonna get something straight forward but
bastok would practical
for two hours motive characters invented
production values and my aunty direction
set a new standard for the job you know
hope is a mistake god max if you can't
fix what's broken challenged
preconceived notions about horror it's
by no means the first movie to warn with
dark comedy and satire I'm not racist
I've seen get out like three times now
what I voted for a long as there's term
like a best present my lifetime
sounds relaxed
[Music]
[Laughter]
then departed that's not mm oh what's
down high school
the images your turn yet oh you're
looking at their site is pretty great it
from all the movies I've seen so far I
think this showing best picture for the
ones that are now made you see oh I
don't know the nominees yes but I would
love a parasite win
George Washington birds
really
oh maybe a Coen brothers would be like
no country have him at the edge of my
seat I don't know which one it's gonna
the revenue
[Music]
it's impossible to imagine the world
without this social media platform
for now though this depicts a legendary
origin story that was relevant in 2010
and remains very much like that's in
2019
I I see your arguments yeah I see your
reasoning mm-hmm I respect it a million
percent wrong oh it's the last Jedi is
the best film in the 2010s honestly
let's not do this everyone fails to
recognize the Ghostbusters remake this
is an interesting list to talk about
I really wish WatchMojo but sometimes
tell you what their criteria is yes to
qualify it's like there are some movies
that I would say here are certainly like
Django Unchained is definitely one of my
favorite movies of the decade and I get
their argument for social network these
lists are so polarizing because it's so
impossible to narrow it down because
you're gonna say the best movies of the
decade and which is a very difficult
list to assemble even though it doesn't
really mean that much of a difference
it's just good to specify this is your
opinion this is just this is completely
subjective
yeah it'll help your comments out a lot
yeah cuz I wouldn't say you know for if
we make a list I would say top 10
favourite movies of the last decade and
really specify that and there's none of
these here that I'm like terrible should
it be on here you know like I get why
anyone will put this on their top 10 of
the decade and what they said about
endgame is exactly why a game is my
favorite movie out of the MCU I
personally prefer Irishman over wolf of
wallstreet
and that's just me I prefer a few other
2010 Scorsese flicks over those the
thing that that I did like about this
list is that I think a good decade list
ought to reflect what's going on in
culture at the time as well as just the
quality movies under hype movies and the
enjoyable movies and I felt like that
was arguably what maybe got a more
debatable pick like wolf of wallstreet
onto this list because they're still
like you pointed out a number of people
who idolized jordan belfort even
though he is a despicable guy they
idolized the DiCaprio yeah
and that's an interesting thing to note
about movies like that and it's a part
of the double edged sword movies oh yeah
that's true I don't entirely agree with
the interstellar thing I think there's a
lot that it did visually that makes it
unique and different and the matrix and
Dark City explored a lot of very similar
things in live-action I thought already
and we learning you mean inception yeah
what do I say
interstellar no I mean interstellar
inception yeah out of a decade you could
fill this with a whole bunch of films
that I think matter yeah they try being
as diverse as possible but moonlight on
here they did put get out I think 12
years a slave is another great one pick
personally my favorite movie out of the
2010s it was the 2011 independent action
arthouse flick Drive anyone who knows me
knows how much I love that film it
really struck a chord with me there's a
lot of arthouse action that seems to
have been heavily influenced by that
film yeah and a lot of cinema scores oh
yeah yeah
even some bigger action films have
definitely barf or than we listened to
enough directors you start hearing that
they referenced that movie so I think
Drive has actually been quite an
influential film and that's a movie I
saw in the theaters without having seen
any trailer and then I ended up going
back to the theaters a couple times just
because I loved it so much so yeah I
would if I had a list Drive would be my
personal number one and I know a lot of
people wouldn't say that in terms of Chi
feel like you know yeah we got a compact
movie on here yeah I think their
reasoning for putting endgame on here
makes a lot of sense I think out of the
2010s in terms of comic book movies I
think Logan is the better choice the
cinematic universe equivalent in terms
of like influence and for something that
makes for a totally unique theater to go
and experience what the cinematic
universe is done with the MCU yeah and
game for sure
I think Logan's a just a better picture
well Logan can stand like you can watch
Logan on its own without having to mine
a whole bunch of other Conte
endgame is terrific and it is everything
that they set it to be here yeah but it
does rely on a bunch of other movies you
can't just watch it out of sequence so
it is an achievement but brass tacks
talking about what film can I put on
that's just gonna be a great film
wall-to-wall and can stand on its own
legs yeah Logan is probably the more
soul but it's also niche ear you know
it's like it's Western it's a bit of a
left turn so it's you know I love that
film though terrific as a terrific movie
I love the Logan everything just a
matter of taste
you know like whiplash I think is one of
the best movies of the decade hands down
I thought ex machina was terrific ex
machina is another great one hey Lala oh
you're gonna get a lot of friends on
this video
la-la-land swept me up hey man I've
watched it months before it got popular
somebody released a tenth of the decade
list just the past week or so and it had
lala land and the artist at the top
oh hell yeah so there you go somebody's
on your team and I kind of lists right
there you go all that Hollywood love
let's just get old Hollywood movies
I don't think comedies get enough
recognition we always go for the weight
and ones like none of these are comedies
no I think the nice guys is one of the
most my whole list is a bunch of Ryan
Gosling enjoyable Ryan Gosling I love
the nice guys there I would I would go
to bat for that one I've seen that movie
a few times and every time I watch it
I'm impressed by how clever it is and
just how tight and well assembled you
know yeah this is what we do make a list
yeah cuz we would just start talking
about all the good movies of the dick
the problem is is is narrowing down a
decade to ten movies you're in snubs
yeah you're going to snub a bunch of
things that are worth putting on a list
yeah and plus my opinion changes upon
like rewatching stuff all the time
mm-hmm like if I didn't rewatch Logan a
months after endgame I might have just
said egg games definitely the one who
deserves would be honored because I
realized Logan like novel Logan's the
moment like the great heart like the
wait you know yeah yeah yeah I'd have
gone to bat for black Klansmen just
because again out of this list
clearly they wanted to choose stuff that
was all
so relevant as well as just quality and
that movie just continues to be relevant
and has so much life and craft to it
like I feel like you can approach that
movie from every angle and it's pretty
great I think hereditary is from
rewatching in on long ago I think that
is a master class in execution it is
exceptionally edited scored conceived on
tone and beautiful it's a very unique
experience I still prefer babadook
they're very similar in a lot of ways
and very different in a lot of ways but
there's a lot of threads that I do think
are similar but I personally found
babadook to be more
that's my mean that just hits my heart
more yeah and it explores it's
supernatural elements in a different and
a more integrated fashion hereditary I
could I can't really argue with it but I
would sooner put on the babadook eye I
connect to that movie more yeah although
yeah I just like hereditary the movie
you step back from it you're just like
wow respect and I'm glad that they put
inception for the fact that it's a
sci-fi film and arrival as well yeah
arrivals a very hard one to contend with
hmm I feel like ex machina probably had
more of an impact though from in terms
of film culture like arrival was the
bigger film yeah but we got the meme of
Oscar Isaac dancing from his machina
denis villeneuve he is a staple of a
director and i wish they'd kind of hone
in on that a little bit yeah the fact
that he has had like a bunt like this
was his decade in a lot of waking
Sicario prisoners laid runners for forty
nine a rival rival and now dude was like
unfilmable the only way i didn't see
what it was it called
enemy the one with Jake Gyllenhaal I
haven't seen that one but the other one
I've seen are their incredible films
speaking of Gyllenhaal - Nightcrawler
with a night crawler would've another
damn good one of them another relevant
movie with social Bleak content being of
relevant revenant
oh hey leo suffering for the art there's
not very many suffering pieces I feel
like he got off easy and yeah well
that's all he had to do was crawl on his
face a few times yeah I mean we go on
and on I respect the list at the time
film this I got 12 K likes and 4 K
dislikes I think it's a decent like
weirdly social network guys was a decent
list all these are deserving and if
anything I was just like huh when we got
to number 1
it's who cares it's just it's someone's
list how dare you not feature this what
do you think they're the pinnacle of
lists right here assemble a 10 based on
10 years worth of movies and and I defy
you to make one that doesn't leave
something deserving it's just not
possible it's impossible social network
is not a film I've ever even care go
read watch respect their reasoning for
it for the relevancy especially that
whole thing about how it's timely and
timeless and very accurate yeah that's
very good that movie yeah that's true
and it proved that at the time whatever
one when it was coming out was like
really we're making the Facebook movie
already and then sure enough it came out
it was relevant it was a quality film
and aspects of that movie have still
stuck around so the original title vote
supposed to be called the Facebook oh
good I mean that would have been perfect
brand recognition the book of faces the
book of face
and then it's just the Necronomicon
where is the Evil Dead remake that was
the number-one horror movie of the 2010s
on nowhere on this list alright guys
well what are your top 10 favourite
movies at the last decade do you have
some go ahead leave them in the comments
chappie you guys can subscribe to
district no no I was like mm doesn't -
yeah okay hey why don't you do that
thing where you subscribing click
Belle's yeah Eric thanks a lot buddy
I hope you're having a great new year I
hope you're not getting too hammered I
hope you're not somewhere in the back
alley shooting up toward pills sucking
off or something glorying a hole but if
that's what brings you joy in 2020 you
do that welcome the new decade in with a
hard bang ha ha ha I'm gonna get an eric
horseman tattoo on my bicep and then we
can motion together in an alleyway
somewhere
[Laughter]